- [Instructor] So we're
told that silver oxide
decomposes according to
the following equation.
So for every two moles of silver oxide
it decomposes into four moles of silver
and one mole of molecular oxygen.
How many grams of silver
oxide are required to produce
1.50 liters of oxygen gas
at 1.22 atmospheres
and 30 degrees Celsius?
So I want you to pause this video
and see if you can figure this out.
And I'll give you a little bit of a hint.
So you're used to saying,
well, if I know how many moles
of oxygen I need to produce,
then I need twice as many
moles of silver oxide
because the ratio of moles of silver oxide
to molecular oxygen is two to one.
But they don't tell us how many moles
of molecular oxygen we're producing.
They give us volume and
pressure and temperature.
But a little bit of a
hint is the ideal gas law.
It tells us that PV is equal to NRT.
And if we solve for N,
remember N is just the number of moles.
So we divide both sides by RT.
We get PV over RT is equal to N.
And it looks like they
gave us all of this stuff.
The pressure is right over here.
The volume is right over here.
The ideal gas constant,
we can look that up,
and then temperature,
we just have to convert
this right over here into Kelvin.
And to help you there,
I will give you some of the
constants and the conversions.
And so see if you can
have a go at this now.
All right, now let's work
through this together.
So the number of moles of oxygen
is going to be equal to
the pressure of our oxygen.
So 1.22 atmospheres
times the volume of oxygen,
times 1.50 liters
divided by the ideal gas constant.
And we have to use the right one
that is going to deal with
atmospheres, liters and Kelvin.
So if we're dealing with
atmospheres, liters and Kelvin,
then we'll use this ideal
gas constant right over here.
So divided by 0.08206.
I'll write the units here.
Liters, atmospheres,
divided by moles,
and also divided by Kelvin.
So this is our ideal gas constant,
and then we're going to multiply that
times the temperature in Kelvin.
Now they only gave us two
significant figures here.
They're only going to the ones place.
So let's only go only go to the ones place
when we convert to Kelvin.
So let's just add 273 to this.
So this is going to be times 303 Kelvin.
And let's make sure the units work out.
That cancels with that,
that cancels with that,
that cancels with that.
And if we have a dividing
by moles in the denominator,
then that's just going to become a moles
eventually in the numerator.
So this is going to be
approximately equal to
1.22 times 1.5 divided by 0.08206.
And then we're going to
also divide that whole thing
by 303.
Is equal to this.
And let's see how many
significant figures.
We have three, we have three,
we have a lot more than
three right over here.
And then we have three right over here.
So I'm going to round to
three significant figures.
So 0.0736.
So 0.0736 moles
of molecular oxygen is how many we need,
how much we need to
produce to get this volume
at this pressure at this temperature.
And so we're going to need two times this
number of moles of silver oxide,
because notice for every one mole
of molecular oxygen we produce
we need twice as many
moles of silver oxide.
So let's multiply this times two.
So, times two gets us,
and once again, three
significant figures, 0.147.
So this is approximately 0.147 moles
of silver oxide that we need to produce.
But they're not asking us how many moles
of silver oxide are needed.
They're asking us how many grams.
So we just have to multiply
this times the molar mass.
So let's first figure out the
molar mass of silver oxide.
I'll write it right over here.
So silver oxide's molar
mass is going to be
whatever the molar mass
of silver is times two,
plus the molar mass of oxygen.
And so let me get the periodic
table of elements out.
Molar mass of silver is
107.87, oxygen, 16.00.
So that gives us 107.87
for each of the silvers.
And then plus 16.00 for
the oxygen, which gives us
107.87 times two is equal to that.
Let's see it goes to the hundredth place.
And then plus 16.00 also
goes to the hundreds place.
So we'll go to 231.74.
Also going to the hundreds place.
I'm just keeping track of
the significant figures
when we're adding.
So this is 231.74 grams
per mole of silver oxide.
And so if we take the
moles of silver oxide
and we multiply that times
231.74 grams per mole,
and notice the moles cancel out,
and we're just left with the
grams, which is what we want.
This is going to be
approximately equal to,
and we're going to end up
with three significant figures
'cause we have three here and five here.
So we're going to take that
and multiply it by 0.147.
Gives us this.
And three significant
figures would be 34.1.
Approximately 34.1 grams
of silver oxide is required
to produce this much oxygen.